l'euthanasie tout le monde en talent
alors pourquoi ne pas être honnête
et pourquoi ne pas dire du moment où
vous les soulager un malade
et bien voilà la recette pour le
soulager vraiment fin des années 70 le
débat sur l'accompagnement de la fin de
vie était déjà vif en france dans la
société la sphère politique ou le milieu
médical
la question divise le médecin léon
schwartzenberg était l'un des rares à
défendre ouvertement l'euthanasie multi
disposent de médicaments injectables par
brevet neige qui peuvent se permettre de
faire dormir nana vous aller jusque là
donc je vous réponde honnêtement oui à
l'époque aucun texte non cadrée la
question de la fin de vie en 1978 le
sénateur henri caillavet été le premier
homme politique à faire une proposition
de loi vers certains vous reprochent
d'organiser par la loi
la mort d homme je veux organiser ma
propre mort mon corps m'appartient il
n'a personne à partir de personnes
lorsque par suite de circonstances et
notamment d'incurabilité je suis devenu
un être inerte végétatif il m'appartient
et à moi seul de dire si je veux
continuer à vivre d'une manière
artificielle le projet sera rejetée par
le sénat procède médecin ou de fadhli
qui met fin à la vie de leurs patients
de leurs proches malades continuent
alors d'alimenter le débat
ce n'est qu'en 2005 suite à l'histoire
du jeune tétraplégique vincent humbert
qu'une loi est enfin beauté c'est la loi
leonetti le parlement a tranché en
faveur du droit au laisser mourir un
droit qui limite l'acharnement
thérapeutique
quand les soins ne servent qu'à
maintenir artificiellement la vie les
malades en phase terminale pourront eux
décidé d'arrêter leur traitement
malgré cette avancée législative
l'euthanasie et le suicide assisté reste
interdite en france
une alternative que réclamait pourtant
chantal sébire en 2008
le cas de cette femme ravivait nouvelle
fois le débat sur l'euthanasie
certains appelaient alors à modifier la
loi pour introduire une formule
d'exception qui fasse que lorsqu'une
personne n'a pas d'autre solution que
celle demandée par chantal sébire elle
puisse saisir une haute autorité
indépendante qui au cas par cas au vu de
sa situation puisse autoriser de manière
exceptionnelle le médecin procédé à une
injection des tables après de longues
discussions l'assemblée nationale adopte
une nouvelle loi en 2016 un texte qui
fixe notamment un droit à une sédation
profonde et continue jusqu'au décès
limité à certains 4 l'euthanasie active
reste en revanche toujours interdit en
france
[Musique]